and then he went and told the coach i
thought he was gonna get cut from the
team the coach brought me in
and where his he was so intimidating his
name was gary barnett
and we were full of a picture of gary
barnett please i mean hall of fame coach
i think i met him one time
he won a rosebot northwestern he was so
intimidated who didn't
he was the only one ever but
back off my broccolini get your life
together
[ __ ] what happened to your [ __ ]
yeah what happened honey you're doing
well
are you not feeling well i'm not feeling
great i can't stop sweating what
happened
a friend of mine goes oh my mom's
calling my mom's calling see what she
said let's see what your mom says i'm
gonna say i have to work with bernie
today so you know how i'm feeling yeah
let's see what she's put on speaker
hey ma hey are you back fam
back where in
nashville oh no i'm in los angeles still
oh okay
all right well i won't bother you i was
just wondering how you were doing
we got some new king in the sting merch
they all got to get you some
oh well i want that um
group of podcasters remember in like a
little mug or something
oh the artwork yes okay
yeah i gotta we're going to work with
brendan right now someone was doing some
deep breathing exercises first
okay yeah i'm watching her i have
earlier today been watching the stevie
would be
thinking did you do that like
prior to this visit out there no
oh that was a current one yeah and that
guy is really
oh i don't know what's happening with
him he seems like a nice
fellow yeah yeah he is a nice fella
um you're busy now i was i will uh
when you get back to nashville uh sunday
okay so okay we'll give you i'll give
you a call you're enjoying
your time out there yeah it's been
pretty nice i'm just wondering i just
thought
stevie kid was so alarming to me
what the the whole podcast is alarming
no the stevie fella that fella oh
he's alarming to you yes ma'am
yeah huh i don't know that wouldn't
i mean i'm only into it a little bit but
that's second time he's been on there
and um i wasn't alarmed the first time
well you will be after this one mom
you're wisdom when are you yeah i'm just
at the studio right now we're just about
to start all right what's up mama
that's brendan what's up mama hey
brendan
i'll call you when you're back in
nashville okay
all right love you see you i love you
bye
that's sweet well yeah you tried you
know you tried debate and she wasn't
she was in biting she likes the episodes
she watched it she liked it
but yes he said he wasn't alarming the
first time wow i said just wait
just wait you know that fella just
alarmed me man i didn't know did you
feel that does that happen a lot of
y'all's culture chin where people start
to just
devolve as they get to a certain age he
went deep though
i thought i would hide i thought it was
interesting he's pretty open book yeah
if he was secretive about it i'd be more
alarmed if he's like yeah
i can't tell you what i'm into i'm like
oh this is weird yeah he's pretty
harmless
yeah yeah yeah you're right harmless
unless you're a
fake ass yeah it's pretty harmless
and oh my god what is this
one i have darker ones which one do you
like
okay yeah i got some over there in the
closet yeah i'll show you really
really but these are nicer these are way
nicer than myself
yeah i have so many questions i don't is
this the date we sent them on
i don't even know man things are looking
up things this date was way more lit
than chins i'll tell you that
yeah yeah man what is this i don't know
i don't know they had breast meat at
benihana though i know that
yeah boy tji freda is doing all they can
to bring people back huh
jesus christ bro i just want to say
right now
asian hate is stopped apparently okay it
has been put an
end to is it off nick can you take it
off you don't know what it's from nick
uh so do you know who david so is joe
joe yes yeah yeah yeah he used to have a
show called dvdsa
and stevie wiebe was a character on it
and that was just one bit most
most of it's been white from the
internet but that's like why did you get
white from the internet
uh i think someone i mean god someone
told me in like 2013 he had some like
allegations and this was just like
it was oh he's just trying to yeah
stevie had some
uh no no david chow david joe
and this is all hearsay i have no i i
don't know a lot about david show
we got to get stevie some allegations
man no we don't want that we got to find
my girl dude
validations are gonna help that i don't
know these days man the way that
everybody
it's like you know even jeffrey dahmer
had women who wanted to reach out to him
in jail did you know that the night
stalker had
a freaking squad of women yeah he went
on a dating show
the nightstalker yeah no he did really
nick man i wish two guys had computers
that could look it up
huh i said i wish two guys had computers
what are you looking up huh you guys
where are you guys at today
was uh you guys watching freaking uh
full house online
yeah there's your family feud rerun over
there
richard romero's on dating show
looks a little evil oh he does look a
little bit little bit like him now
now you you should this guy's serial
killer i don't know i could have found
this in 10 seconds
oh wow that's him dude that's not really
he killed that lady right nine times
when it really gets good in retrospect
it has got to be one of the creepiest
moments on tv that's so
hollywood says i always get my
girlfriend that guy looks like it's
softball dating game killer is one of
the country's most notorious criminals
they told us that they had found robin
oh
okay we get it okay it's getting dark oh
we just want to see a sierra kill on a
dating
we're just trying to find stevie at date
okay we had any
we've got some coming in we had anything
happening with that nick
yeah we just started getting some uh
entrance in we gotta sift through them
we want to keep stevie safe so yeah
we'll uh we'll be sifting through them
and next week we'll have enough or
two weeks we'll have an update and maybe
we could do a thing where he burns the
uh the sex toy you know yeah
or or or we put uh dynamite on and blow
it up because burning
i mean it's gonna be a 70 minute video
you think yeah that ass
is pretty sturdy oh unbelievable i think
we blow that i think we put some
m80s in that [ __ ] yeah with all the oil
in it just
blows up everywhere watch him
maybe him at his date they go to the
burning of his text
or they both put their hands on like the
thing and go
i like that emotion like at the end of a
little house on the prairie can you
bring that up nick little house on the
prairie last episode
oh this was good
this nickelback yeah they put it to
nickelback why would they put nickel
back to it
you put anything to it yeah you're right
i celebrate somebody put an old guy
falling off a cliff to nickelback and
it's still lit
still slaps i mean it makes you care
about the guy a little yeah
here's the thing about anybody they blew
up the town because the rich people came
and took it yeah it makes sense
they said all right you can have our
town and then they blew it called abbott
kenny but also
um anybody who's gonna go on a date with
stevie weeby they know what he's into
so they're already familiar with it it's
not like these girls just like yeah i
know nothing about them let me freaking
sign up for this
yeah they know that he's into those dark
oil art oh bro bro he should work at a
jiffy lube
you know he should work at an
all-african-american jiffy lube it looks
like well that's not a bad idea ooh it's
not a bad idea yeah
they only do it impalas yeah
and paul walls their number one client
break
lives matter takes this to houston yeah
i love that
oh my god here's a woman right here no
into stevie no no like i said we haven't
haven't found the correct suitor josh
no okay there's been a lot of cosplay
men also that have submitted i will say
that
some furries uh or some larps
live-action role-playing
yeah yeah it's just one me in the game
yeah
yeah yeah it's more larpers it's more
like construction workers who just gave
who are only you know doing pills now a
lot of truck drivers looking for a
road lizard yeah a lot of people just
out there with pvc pipe a couple of
dudes
perked out with some pvc pipe freaking
fencing on the side of a freaking
highway
you just want to beat them up huh yeah
yeah a lot of right-wing larpers maybe
dude first of all i want to see
right-wing larpers attack a renaissance
fair am i the only one
that would be sick and when does that
kind of stuff start yeah forget storm in
the capital man start
taking over these larp sessions yeah or
get larpers to go up there and attack
the
uh that portland park or whatever
whatever they keep taking those pictures
[Laughter]
the amanda fort knox yeah that would be
sick uh two weeks ago we talked about
taxidermy it was our one of our kinder
stinger topics and someone wanted to
show some off it's nick's old
oh wow she got those taxidermied fronts
huh yeah apparently she stuffed them tit
hey guys it's becca from california and
i want to introduce you to a friend of
mine
a little he is my first ever bull
elk shot in colorado on a hunting trip
with my dad
yes i eat him it's been almost two years
and i'm still eating him
um not to be too joe rogan but i try not
to eat store-bought meat
and i got him stuffed because i wanted
to
always have a token of the hunting trip
with my dad because it was like
the best week of my life and it was
amazing did you bait him in with the
team anyway
i love you guys let me know if you ever
want to go on a hunt
gang gang shoot stuff oh yeah no she's
beautiful man
what are you bro oh my gosh one leg
no that's inked up man oh no that's
prosthetic full left side's inked up
that's a super batting she will shoot
you right in the [ __ ] face theo
so what's your words man i didn't say
anything did i
no i was the one kind of hinting at her
yeah
enticing the dare with her tits yeah
dude but
with the ct reverse psychology over here
okay
first of all i think that's a prosthetic
limb brother no dog
she's eating zoom in on that limb go
ahead look at that great art man
oh there's the oh she got the dare
tattooed before she even killed
oh yeah calling her shot and there's
like bobby lee that looks better than
that freaking one that
we didn't have any close-ups on i wish
we had he texted me at 9pm with it
oh you're trying to get pictures of his
tats bro the first hat and i love both
these boys
look nothing like bobby lee not a
champion nobody supported me
no i support you i said it looks like it
goes from the con actually
there oh there there it looks like bobby
if they
found him in a lake after several days
yeah bobby lake
yeah it's the exact same
yeah it's that exact same as that it's
just grown up
also what artist did that why is the
nose all [ __ ] up like that
i don't know she looks like anne spank
right there
i'll tell you that and look at all those
hieroglyphs under it and look there's
andrew santino over there on the right
oh that's cool doing a cannonball um
i think that's actually jeremy watkins
[Laughter]
oh yeah that's the scissor bros shirt he
came up to me yesterday he's like hey
i think the ewok looks more like bobby
no [ __ ] that's spot-on stevie couldn't
even handle that when i told him
oh that's beautiful though look i mean
you see that it's good art man and it's
great to see it
um what's going on dude so would you
dude i
a friend of mine goes oh yeah try this
new pre-workout mix man i need like you
know
caffeine stuff like that so i took this
pre-workout mix i looked at the label
i think i said to nick says it's called
chaotic or psychotic pre-workout mix
oh it might be ketamine no i think it's
meth and viagra is in that thing because
i could not stop sweating
christian i know you like to get high on
your adderall just take one little scoop
of this dude and it's so
i couldn't stop sweating i could have
[ __ ] built a
spaceship to mars out of sweat oh dude
that with adderall you'd be
unstoppable or you're gonna die because
my heart was beating like a goddamn
hummingbird
it's my [ __ ] was like we're gonna get
work today
we're going overtime we're gonna do a
drop set of [ __ ]
i'm going to turn out the ac i can tell
it's still still hitting you
know my heart's a million miles an hour
i see everything i feel
i feel like one of those you know those
monkeys with the big guys
that's how i feel like i want to attack
you right now
it's so weird do you bring any for the
boys no don't take it
do not [ __ ] take it bro i don't need
anything you don't you definitely don't
need that
okay i'll see you snorting on the side
of the highway in a week
don't do it man i seriously think
there's meth in that thing
yeah it's scary out there gummy candy
it's called that's not baiting for
children
and it also says psychotic across the
middle of it what are you guys trying to
do
it says energy focus pumps psycho
dude i was in there like i'm so excited
it just [ __ ]
i couldn't stop dude i thought y'all are
just trying to go to the gym
dude i'm trying it's a thick boy summer
man i'm trying in shape
by any means necessary but that's where
i draw the line but didn't you weren't
you already doing fitness like
do you need this man's stuff to how do
you know this man he's my buddy
is he and he was just like hey this is
what i use you you take a bunch of
coffee and other [ __ ] why you can't why
not take this
and i looked at the label and said do
not take seven hours before we go into
bed
and also don't take more than one scoop
well i did two scoops
because i thought i'm so caffeinated all
the time this isn't gonna do anything
wrong brendan wrong oh two scoops it was
like it was almost like an x-ray i could
see through people in the gym dude it
was sick really
yeah ooh uh two scoops
two scoops call me scoops
at your funeral what would you guys say
at brendan's funeral you think
let's get a couple of words from yeah if
i keep this up you're gonna you be ready
well i want to be prepared right now i
want to get a little prepared so you're
not
shocked even though you're going to be
g-o-n-e
that's gone yeah what do you think chan
what would you say if you had to say a
couple words that bees drop
we were buddies right not not friends
buddies
it was great to be his buddy and also
now that he's gone and
my family's even like then [ __ ] chin
after all brendan's like
brendan you called me that you called me
he's been listening to you for freaking
almost six years
time for you to listen and also now that
brendan's gone
basically 99.9 percent of my career is
over
he doesn't show my job yeah so anyone
he's gonna start networking so anybody
needs a really good engineer producer
producer let me know man
so bring business cards today i've dm to
everyone at this funeral
it's insane nick what do you think man
okay christian let's get something from
christian man from the little rib
eye right there a little meat sock or
whatever i don't really know
i'd say i know i've known brennan for
about a month and a half
it was a great month and a half and i'd
probably like maybe post like an
instagram story
from like the fighter in the kids
account like me next uh
brennan's coffin or something or r.i.p
to the fighter
uh yeah i love you christian i don't
know if you're speaking at my funeral
what do you mean some of the people that
are closest to you dude
this is how it's going to go nick's got
a few words he wants to say dude this is
dark huh hey man i just used some
pre-workout stuff
i'll be all right bro will you bucko
have you met you okay dude you couldn't
look any more like the rat came from
teenage mutant
ninja turtles yeah yeah oh that works
you look identical to him that's the
exact [ __ ] outfit
dude put me back in the freaking ring
man rappaport you want some of this
[ __ ] smoke you come to new york
did he yep nice time dude that little
freaking
200 grain [ __ ] all of a sudden the
knicks get good and he moves back
yeah i remember when porzingis was gonna
beat his ass for saying something and
then kevin garnett was going to they
moved closer to kevin garnett
i remember watching him yell for two
years on his phone yelling at donald
trump into a video dude once donald
trump lost the election i texted him to
go
what are you gonna do now what are you
gonna do dude your your entire bit's
over
yeah go back can't do that for biden
he's not giving you any material
there's nothing no but uh unbelievable
yeah listen i've seen the candy sting
fans and a lot of you
need some help all right you need better
help just not any help you need better
help is there something interfering with
your happiness
or achieving your goals what is it man
better help will assist you
with your needs and match you with your
own license profession now therapist
quit talking your buddies around the
water cooler at work we're talking to
your best friend at night in bed on
facetime
talk to real licensed professional all
right the service is available
worldwide log into your account anytime
send a message your counselor
all right better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if you're
not not feeling the one you're with it's
more affordable than traditional offline
counseling
and financial aid is also available
better help once you start living a
happier life
today visit betterhelp.com cats that's
better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help they're recruiting more
counselors in all 50 states all right
this podcast king of the sting is
sponsored by betterhelp and kingston
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s you know your boy loves watches
i love watches theo doesn't wear watches
he doesn't believe in time
whatever i do but if you're gonna wear a
watch you gotta look fly man
so that's why movement came to the call
man
they got dope watches how about the new
minimal sports dive watch so
sleek professional looking you never
know you could dive down 100 meters in
deep water
beat up a few sharks collect some coral
maybe a pearl i don't know
you'll figure it out movement watches
have a looking quality of four to five
hundred dollars
that you're gonna pay at the department
store but it's a fraction of that man
because they're doing it all online
they're cutting out the middle man
you can get a beautiful watch shipped
straight to your door
for free if you don't love it ship it
right back you got nothing to lose all
right
they also got blue light glasses maybe
you're sitting on a computer all day
you're on your phone all day this is
going to help the man
it helps with eye strain poor sleeping
patterns all right they
the frames look dub you don't look like
a nerd in these things if you want to
elevate your look with style that
doesn't break the bank then join the
movement get 15
off today with free shipping free
returns by going to mvmt.com
kats again that's mvmt.com
k-a-t-s a couple weeks ago
uh we asked people for and one of our
shark takes
segments someone suggested we take
people's confessions like the apology
line yeah yeah yeah and we actually we
actually got some decent ones there
i hope we get a serial killer like the
apology line that'd be so interesting
oh yeah our ratings would go i wonder if
anybody
we know has cereal killed out there and
i want to say something to people i
didn't get to speak at the funeral you
didn't either nick oh right
yeah i didn't like that well it's almost
over
uh so i have a gambling problem and when
you gamble one thing you like is parlays
and if there's one thing brendan could
do it was parlay his career
into the next big step oh this is nice
not finally someone said something
he was an athlete football player to ufc
fighter
to podcaster to stand up to mentor
the man the man the man has a big house
big car i thought i heard mentors
i know you're going through a big dick
it's a big dick oh but even a bigger
heart
oh this is nice man and that's on the
spot
dude and those last couple raises he
gave me were really welcome
god bless him wow stand ovation for my
mom crying
finally ladies and gentlemen it's good
to be here
uh closing out the show for brendan
um one of my fans back saying you saw
that that's fine dude you were mean to
him
it's jay look i'm just happy to be here
mom
i'm just happy to be here with my new
child boston
[Laughter]
and my son chen his
chance thanks dad
but brandon you'll be missed man and we
know you'll be up at the big uh
you know we'll see you in the big
octagon in the sky big daddy
you know we know we'll see you up there
just high on pre-workout just
panhandling by the interstates of the
lord my brother
and you will be missed baby but not
forgotten and i'm getting a huge tattoo
of uh of your son boston on my back
this is so dark and it's going to have
him with a little mexican flag
and it's going to say these colors don't
run
these guys don't run amigo
and i'm also going to sell an nft of me
walking up that muddy hill at your
funeral
but man uh you're one of the hardest
working guys i know
and you were loved and you will be
missed this is so dark
[ __ ] give us the apology line [ __ ]
dude
here's the first one hey guys
i saw your post on instagram about uh
leaving something anonymous
and i i want to tell you guys something
that's been going on in my life
[Music]
last year at my sister's wedding
i walked in on her soon-to-be husband
making out
with one of his best men
i told her about it but she just thinks
that i was
too drunk that i didn't see the right
thing
but i know for a fact i saw him suck in
face with that dude
what should i do guys love the show
bye i don't know i think i would rather
thank you first of all and what's a
man's name it's unnamed man no we
yeah we don't want to secretly out there
yeah it's smart
the only way this thing's going to work
if they can go yeah you know
well look brother thanks for sharing it
that's kind of wild to see
i remember uh
i left i've probably gotten high a few
times kiss couple friends
no i'm not no i have not i think a guy
tried to
fill me up one time and take advantage
of me one time
but i don't know i was on pills but um
here's what i'm telling you is this man
i think you'd almost
rather see them blowing each other then
kissing
oh i disagree bubba you think yeah
i don't know what because maybe who
knows maybe you know something you're
saying there's a really like a
passionate relationship if they're like
sucking face
yeah i mean you're blowing some guy you
don't know that good at a party or
whatever
they could just be really italian if
they're just blowing each other that's
what cuomo says
yeah i don't know man yeah
sucking face i'd rather see some dude
sucking face than sucking dick
tuxedo you know i know you're gay
i don't know man first of all i'm not
doing that
second of all if i walk in your say you
say it's your wedding right yeah
and i walk in the back and i'm sucking
days with gallons
and you know you're giving a frontside
piggyback ride to a little freaking
mukbang over there little
naked naked or in our toxins
naked or in our tuxes what does it
matter it matters dude
because we're just playing a game having
fun before i go out there and [ __ ]
get married
or it's pretty gay if we're both naked
man
well i think y'all you know talks i
don't remember exactly what it was
but i think y'all knows tuxes but you're
giving that little front side
freaking uh that wheelbarrow yeah yeah
you're giving that front side little
march of the penguins so what's his name
what's his burn head whatever his name
is over there
haircut meat hawk a [ __ ] kid who
works in here dude
meat hog could you call him meatball
whatever he's italian meatball works
my bad meatball yeah okay you like
meatball better christian
uh yeah that's actually been my like
nickname for about
15 years well it's give me another 15.
yeah now your nickname is frontside
penguin
and what is this this is the guy's heart
rate during the sex thing
what would you do though brenden the guy
needs suggestion the thing is you walk
in on your buddy who's getting married
and he suck and face some dude
who knows he might be a little drunk
he's like dude i'm going out there man
yeah you know i'll see where it is
should we hear another one yeah let's
hear another one and that guy look we
didn't talk
listen if you're the brother it's like
yeah he's been your sister dude all
right and he made out with his buddy
before it went out there
it's weird but also be cool man yeah you
[ __ ] cool don't ruin their entire
[ __ ] lives you know he was one last
hurrah maybe maybe he was gay back in
the day for pay
yeah i didn't mean to rhyme all that but
you get the idea and also at least
somebody's marrying your sister
yeah you know what i'm saying like you
know how many people would love to have
their sisters married
doesn't matter if it's to a gay dude a
mailman
a freaking nick no no no no my sister i
want to get married
i'm sorry oh should should we start
taking some submissions for your sister
what if we connect stevie and your
sister oh she's single
no she's actually not she's in the ass
boy
she is actually for a living oh that's
right
wow the one time nick has a great
opportunity
this is a match made in heaven move
cloud next check it out minneapolis
man this is just she does colonics man
it's exact thing that the cv needs
yeah it's finally time for him to get
off his [ __ ]
he could work at her office because he
loves asses she could teach him the
[ __ ]
the ropes man he could just come in
there hey bob
hey guys i'm gonna get into your ass
yeah i'm gonna get everything
out of your ass i'm texting her asking
if she go on a date with him
she comes to l.a all the time how old is
she uh 38
37. that's perfect steven i think we've
seen her before too
65. yeah stevie yes stevie's
people yeah yeah uh this is a shoe and
nick don't be a
[ __ ] block dude well he also said though
now look i don't want to say the
absolutely messed her up dude
she has a boyfriend you said she she
does oh dude this is info we could have
used two minutes ago
this thing's a dead end bubba but look i
would think just be happy your sister
has
a beautiful lady right sister on the
left and the and the right my but the
one on the right is married
they're both your sisters it's before
and after the colonics they're
blood-related
hey they're sorry hey they're both
beautiful
hey they're blood related your blood
related to them yeah
damn wow good for good
[Laughter]
if i had nice teeth i'd look exactly
like natalie unfortunately
yeah probably not but um i like where
you're at though
beautiful ladies beautiful family why
did someone comment goes fart
sister sister what what's wrong with
people
well the comment on there was fart that
was actually my sister's caption
oh wow
yep that's your sister yeah she loves
colonics man that's her life are you
guys close
huh yeah yeah she went yeah i've met her
before
yeah yeah she went to dinner uh first
thing she
she started a podcast with like seven
listener and first thing she did was ask
theo if he'd be on it i was so pissed
i was so pissed oh i thought it was
appropriate i asked
i've been asked for a while people were
like hey man i'm doing a thing where i'm
interviewing uh spirits of deceased uh
native americans
man love to have you on we got episode
six coming up
we're actually gaining some steam man
yeah last one got
30 listeners yeah it's called dances
with ghosts
yeah it's like i'm okay i'm like let me
know when you get to 100 episodes and
then we'll think about it that's what
you told her
how many did she do i think she's
getting there oh no she's still
kicking it yeah yeah she uses like lead
generation for her business and stuff
because even like
she's talking about like asses and stuff
uh they try to just talk about careers
but i think she pigeon holds it in there
no pun intended
you'll pigeonhole daddy well look fella
i think you just got to be happy your
sister's married i think these days
don't be a hater man
yeah and i think you you know every now
and then
check in with the guy make sure as long
as he's taking care of your sister
you know like you know what i would do
i'd hire a pride of him
private investigator see what he's doing
on those
happy hour nights you feel me no i don't
you don't think he's you don't think he
already saw him kissing a man yeah but
we gotta look more into it maybe that
was the last
gay hurrah for him before he go walks
out to the altar
or maybe it's not maybe that was just
the start of it and now he's
oh he's going up that poop shoot every
friday night happy hour
oh god i know the guy who called in
could uh
let his brother-in-law know that he
knows
but not tell him that he told the sister
and she didn't believe him or whatever
and then
and then he just got a he's got like a
free
servant you know like a sitcom yeah yeah
that's true i think or you just get
drunk at thanksgiving and freaking let
the family know
yeah i agree light them up over that
stuff
like hey jerry remember that time it's
like making out with jeff before he got
married and like
what solid jeff's gay y'all
enjoy enjoy the turkey yeah and be lit
doug
if you do that film it for us hey jeff
pass that stuffing am i right
that time i saw you making out with gary
dude drop that [ __ ] thanksgiving bomb
daddy
you have to man that's what thanksgiving
is for it really is
thanksgiving is for boozing watching
detroit lose
and uh front yard gay
allegedly gay fist fights in the family
if you do that record it for us man yeah
brother and good luck to you out there
man thank you
let's see what this guy says hey what's
up brendan what's up theo
uh i ain't gonna say my name because
y'all said to do it anonymously
yeah um yeah i got my roommates with me
got uh three minutes in this house
and uh the thing i want to get off my
chest is
whenever they go out whenever they have
a party
whenever they you know bring something
home and you have leftovers
i eat that [ __ ] i eat it every single
time i eat all of their
food so they have no idea
no they do i don't know what happened no
they do and uh everybody knows yeah
i eat for free
[Laughter]
i eat for free no bubba they know
everybody knows
because you're you're 280 pounds dude
you're the only large man in the house
it's not a mystery dude yeah yeah you
think you've gotten this
entire time without them getting
together figuring out [ __ ]
larry's eating all the [ __ ] leftovers
man brenton maybe he needs the
sustenance maybe this guy's not doing
well
you know you don't know some of these
people or maybe he just like free
[ __ ] food dude and they're bringing
back
fire dishes yeah he's just like hell
yeah put that in the fridge man that'd
be fun tomorrow yeah
and maybe they're so wasting when they
get in the morning like what the heck
when he said
when he said whenever they bring
something home i thought he's referring
to women yeah i thought so too
yeah but my dad that's his women that's
his
that's his outlet yeah that's his sexual
outlet
so i think here's what you do bubba you
eat some of their
um food you eat some of their food but
then you get some whatever the sauces
are and put it on their mouth while
they're drunk
so they think they ate it when they woke
up or just put george just
stained their shirts too oh my god you
boys went wild on that pad thai last
night yeah
meanwhile you got a full belly yeah you
gotta get better at doing it dude you
gotta be the dexter of leftovers
yeah you gotta cover your tracks man you
get caught
and they're gonna hear this and know
it's you for sure the dexter of
leftovers that's great i gotta confess
too i was like
i wasn't this bad i didn't always eat it
i tried to cover my tracks but like
i was dipping into my college roommate's
milk all the time just
tried to take a little bit just washed
something down hoping they wouldn't
notice they all knew
i'm sorry adam michael dude i had a
roommate i had a roommate at the
university of colorado my first roommate
he's on the football team this big tight
end kid way bigger than me
you know when you're when you're
roommates or you know like if there's
something in the studio what's mine is
yours i don't give a [ __ ] i'd have
groceries you could eat them i don't
give a [ __ ]
i ate one hot pocket i come back after
practice
while i was at practice i like took
longer like what happened he was dead no
i wish no he [ __ ] went back home and
put
post-it notes on every single thing
that's his
even individually like you know when you
get individual rappers of pop-tarts
he opened the box put his name on every
single individual [ __ ] pop-tart
we had a straight-up fist fight i threw
him through a glass window
and then he went and told the coach i
thought he can get cut from the team the
coach brought me in
and we're he was so intimidating his
name was gary barnett
gary barnett please i mean hall of fame
coach i think i met him one time
he won a rose bought northwestern he was
so intimidated who didn't
he was the only one ever but
that's why he's a legend but dude there
he is do you see the
logo behind him great coach oh my god
i met that guy one time i was doing a
show at uc
boulder and they introduced us to the
football coach
for some reason i was probably there
dude
but anyway i go to his office i'm so
scared i'm gonna get cut more knee to
knee
and he goes i heard what happened i'm
like i'm so sorry coach like
but we're roommates and we're teammates
i figured we shared everything
yeah so what'd you do i know he got my
face started threatening me
he was and then what no and then i
grabbed him threw him through a glass
window and he goes
well you handled it like he's like i'm
gonna write down community service for
you
and he's like get out of here that's it
man those were the glory days
now kids are getting kicked off the team
fine canceled
yeah i think i don't know if that's the
glory days but
i think that's nice that you guys had
that time together yeah he was
yeah gary barnett you got a standing up
picture of him full body nick
legend he does uh fox college football
now
did he get fired because he said stuff
about that female kicker from katie and
ida
that was that was that was when i was
there yeah wow
and then then my last year was his last
year then they brought in um
hawkins who [ __ ] ruined the team
because he was like you know what we
want all we're only going to take kids
that get really good grades
so we had a team full of white and asian
kids and we lost every game
[Music]
great coach yeah oh i miss him man r.i.p
no he's still alive but yeah i hear you
i miss him as a coach
yeah i do too we had a guy coach steve
for a little while
he needs to give us rides home
those were i
had a pee wee football coach he told us
we were having like a rough day
and he goes you think i played for the
kansas city chiefs acting like this and
i was looking i'm like god that guy
played for the [ __ ]
chiefs he was all fat like there's no
chance he believed in my head i'm like
there's no chance but all the kids right
they play for the chiefs so we listen to
him
and then finally we're done he's again
he was driving us to like dinner or
something like that
and i go man who was your quarterback
was it steve de berg when the chief's
turn i went
i never played for the chiefs i only
played one year of high school football
i'm like god you piece of [ __ ] man
all this time we were believing that's
manipulation man yeah that's called
brothers what happened to you
today's king of the sting is brought to
you by athletic greens the most
comprehensive daily nutritional beverage
i've ever
put down my throat i will deep throat
the hell out of these greens man
because i can't be eating a head of
lettuce all the time or broccoli i can't
be doing none of that
i take this hulk right down the drain
pipe that's right one tasty scoop of
athletic greens contains 75 vitamins
see a multivitamin now i'm drinking it
and it's green tastes good too
we're talking about whole food source
ingredients including a multivitamin
multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more that all
work together to fill the nutritional
gaps in your diet
increase energy focus all right
digestion supports healthy immune system
important right now all without the need
to take multiple products this is
one freaking little little scoop green
down your mouth all right
and right now athletic greens is dumbing
down on supporting your immune system
right they're offering
you guys a free one-year supply of
vitamin d get that d baby
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit the link
today
you basically never have to buy vitamin
d ever again all right
so whatever you're looking for health
peak performance we got you covered man
athletic greens makes this super easy
simple simply visit
athleticgreens.com kats join the health
experts
athletes comics podcasters go-getters
and overall dope-ass people
that take athletic greens again visit
athleticgreens.com kats get your free
year supply of vitamin d and five free
travel packs today
hey little thickies you love food i love
food i like to save money on food that's
where grubhub comes in
i'm part of the club man i'll call that
grub club that grubhub club all right
they got a variety of food from your
local restaurants and you're gonna save
time man and money grub on what you love
take a break from cooking you have
family and friends coming up for the big
fight or watch this podcast whatever it
is you throw
a party every thursday night this
episode drops cool man
you need good food pick it up order
ahead pick up your favorite food from
your favorite restaurants on grubhub
get the food you love with the perks
from grubhub grub what you love
so those are a great start for the
confessions definitely keep sending
those
yeah those were [ __ ] great did we
help the one kid
so
and then the other one dude tell tell
the rat your
uh brother-in-law out at thanksgiving we
i feel like we helped them
yeah yeah i think so and they're really
just trying to get it off their chest i
don't know if
we need to give advice but anything we
can let him know and i'll help this guy
it's uh keeps uh promo code as cats for
a hair loss
this guy's hair is great here the guy is
great here he's got style oh no he's
losing it bubba you think so oh yeah
look his forehead
i don't know you might feel less bad for
him after you hear his plan
okay his first king at her sting it hey
what up king and sting
oh he's australia my name's nick i'm
from nantucket island
uh i love you guys i've been watching
y'all since the jump
it's kind of king intersting at kind of
relationship advice
so a little back story i was dating this
girl for a while
kind of an exhibitionist sent me a lot
of photos and videos and
kind of provocative stuff proven
unfortunately kovid
got a hold of her and she's no longer
with us but she
was a straight up dime i mean like
something you can't even shake a stick
at so
king or sting it starting only fans with
your
hot dead girlfriend i love this guy
uh yeah i
need some cash so that's
where it's at i'll include a pic
as long as brendan doesn't uh start
pushing rope over it and
other than that gang gang buzz buzz let
me know i was just kidding
yeah thanks i like this guy he included
a pic
he didn't and i emailed him back oh he
said i have to subscribe
oh did he really yeah priceless that's
good businessman businessman that's a
businessman that's mark cuban
that's amazing that's the next mark
cuban dude yeah that is definitely
mark nantucket for sure uh dude
so only fan let me ask you this when you
did watch porn
if you found out your favorite porn star
passed away
would you stop watching her movies well
i
always thought that they should have a
deceased section like an r.i.p section
um but yeah i think it's weird to watch
something maybe it's somebody that's
deceased if they're a lot but i don't
know maybe that's why they did it so
it'd still be out there i still listen
to michael jackson
yeah but you're not listening and having
sex with the kids
oh jesus you know i'm saying if that was
the all like if that's what you know
yeah then be different i feel like i
mean i'll why
i don't know yeah i'll still listen to
nirvana
you will yeah will you that's a good
point yeah i will
that's a really good point brendan
somehow thanks man uh
here's the thing about his only fans
with his deceased girlfriend who got
coveted i love it
i think you have to honor the family
somehow though build up i don't think
the family's gonna dig it but also the
families he asked for all the money
and then also how many picks you have
dude how long is this gonna last maybe
three months
but let's say you have a lot maybe three
months worth of material then what dude
he's got three months hurrah and then
he's gonna be getting his [ __ ] pale
ass on there
taking ass pics and stuff well then i
think you start faking you hire somebody
that looks like
her who is ill to do it
and and say oh this is towards the end
of her run
yeah and she's still sending him yeah
she's getting older lady
like that old saggy ass like look what
it did to her ass
what kova did to her yeah um oh you
think you still post
good pics yeah i think you want to honor
the quality that's one thing i don't
like about i don't have any only fan
subscriptions but
i i i think you want to honor the
quality of
putting out good stuff you know do you
have any uh chin
i don't nick you do no my girlfriend
christian nick can't do any of that i
got i got a
i got a buddy who has only fans still
allowed to be here today
nick has been put on notice several
times it's good
breaking bad habits it's good no it's
good
good for you man yeah i got a buddy with
a bunch only fans account
what about chunk meat which you got fam
[Applause]
i mean i've subscribed to like one or
two
wait wait wait wait wait wait nobody's
believing that meatballs because hey
they were always girls from high school
so like i always want to be like oh what
are they doing
like i wanted to see what they were
posting because i mean why not
it's girlfriend is it good stuff no i
immediately regret spending the money my
boy i mean he probably has
15 to 20 only no man how dare you
he probably has 50 or 20 only fan
accounts that he looks at he shows me
the videos
dude i mean they are getting after are
they
dude i mean because they got to get that
money man it's like god damn girl
porn when does it end you know
i also don't like how that when you sign
up for only fans they can see
like your name like if you don't if
you're not smart enough to like put like
a fake name
they can when you subscribe to someone's
account they can see who you are we'll
be smart enough yeah come on
yeah okay you're talking about that
happened to you no no no yeah yeah like
when i first signed i put a fake name
when i first signed up i thought i was
like why would people not do this
true yeah like i don't like that nate
like i don't like how you can see their
your information if it was completely
anonymous i'd be on only offense
what name did you put meatball uh i
think i pull like
john white or something like that i put
something right in the middle hold on
i'm from like wednesday talking about
somebody that came over on the mayflower
dude
john white
meanwhile there's 200 john white's
following the lady
john white ball yeah now are some of
them more expensive than others
cats in the world there are some girls
who are busted that like will make their
account like 30 to like 50 and then like
you click on it
and we'll say one picture one video i'm
like people
subscribe to that but they'll charge 50
bucks a month like up to 50 bucks a
month some people
and they'll post like maybe one thing
yeah you seem pretty into it
you see what happens a lot of details
you go to the library do we have it's
called the library it's not
hard to like once you go on at once like
oh really figure it out like oh
look i'll see like the only fan's ads
like i'll click on it just to see
you know a lot about it bubba yeah you
know a lot about it meatball
yeah i like to go on and see what they
like see how much they're charging so
it's not judging dude
hey you're not in the court of law here
man yeah
his main concern is the business
practices
maybe i can help them out maybe i can
get them more money you know not a bad
idea
sure man yeah jesus christ that shake is
great though man
great shakespeare thanks bro i
appreciate that no it's probably why
oh i hit her on oh dude i'll tell you
this to a girl there was a girl no i
never met this guy before
um i met a girl from south africa
at the smoothie shop how'd it go
she had a kid she's an all pear girl
she's a
la uh like a babysitter okay and she's
watching
yeah she had a kid in there with her and
she gave him a large smoothie this kid
bro
but the smoothie was bigger than the
kids sucking it she just wanted to shut
them up
that's a good way to do it and so i was
trying to flirt with her but then i feel
like she was asking me questions back
and then i just didn't ask her for her
number i just got scared
you didn't get her instagram or nothing
no i thought about it but i did it
maybe you'll see her there tomorrow or
something you know that's true so what'd
this chick look like
give me a visual daddy she's pretty tall
she's south african
love it and you bring up great white
sharks
i did i talk about sharks real quick and
then i talked about
i like being in africa and then she was
kind of milling around a little and i
just should have asked oh she's waiting
yeah can we put out a missed connections
uh
yeah we might as well put one out um it
was at the roback store
so over there off event off of ventura
and
balboa i hope it works out but also i
did my first site at the comedy store
last night
oh how'd it go it was in the main room
huh
in the main room or how filled
40 people maybe it was so weird it was
like a table
nothing not just a table like literally
when you got off the stage you just kind
of walked between the tables it was just
no
you can never do right usually right it
was just so bizarre i mean the
jeff scott isn't there anymore it's
because he passed away you know and so
it's just different right yeah it was
just different
i'm holding out to june 15th it was bad
leslie jones dropped it was bad it was
it was not a good night did you see any
of your boys um spade
was there love spade bur and maniscalco
were there i didn't see them
um they were there before me and
yeah there was some different people
there it was cool it was definitely just
weird to be back in the building like
the doors weren't all open like
you had to kind of going through the
kitchen like you just popping
it was like slow ball over there [ __ ]
so but i did ask joe rogan for those
tickets
and to the july 10th what do you say he
said i got you covered bro just remind
me in a couple of weeks
that sucks you got to do the second
reach out though
so i'm going to light some prayer
candles because a week before i'm like i
[ __ ] forgot man i gave him the
campaigns or some [ __ ] and then i have
to just sit there
and hold the camera's bow and arrow
collection the whole time
what else you got what else you
oh we got some cats in the wild yeah
this still has an alpaca who's that
china
oh my is this long neck yeah
we gotta check in with long neck and see
what happened to that guy remember where
you're hanging out with those guys
he knocked up a porn star i think ah
poor porn star
but you know how easy it will be to have
that baby
just grab it right by that little neck
like a slinky yeah it'd be like one of
those old whistles
that's hilarious right there dude oh
that's pretty close baby
you want to tickle that nickel baby
there's your brother right there meaty
[ __ ] bacon strap there's your brother
right there
[ __ ] gristle nugget there's your
brother back for you
back when white people weren't employing
them you know back in the old days
what up it's pearly white i got a king
interesting at first pearly white
coaching youth sports i figured you guys
would have a good take because uh
big brown he looks like the guy that
coaches but doesn't have a kid on the
team
and theo he looks like the guy that goes
to the games and doesn't have a kid on
the team
[Laughter]
to be honest i thought about last night
when i was watching the kids class
they're doing something like oh god they
get
teach him how to shrimp man like they he
was just like oh he'll pick it up
learning from the older kids i'm like or
he could teach him the technique
and he was going like oh let me in there
man you wanted to teach him oh so bad oh
you should have got out there i did
water break tiger didn't get water so i
was like hey come here and i'll show
them like do this do this
and then i put them back out there yeah
i loved it man i'm like i could get used
to this
dude give me a tiger clipboard tiger
shaub yeah fighting at 50 pounds
fighting at 55.
now now here's here's the thing with how
soon can he fight
oh oh i don't want him to fight man
here's the thing about none of us want
him tiger's a sweet boy tigers
how's it ever gonna get two belts like
that freaking guy right there if he
doesn't [ __ ] get out it's gonna be a
long journey man
yeah my problem about tiger though is
he's such a sweet boy he's really nice
i'm like dude this is the one place
where you can unleash your fury
you're bigger and more athletic than all
these kids and stronger like this is the
one
safe space you can let go of all that
aggression yeah so once he gets that
but he's so nice like he'll panic hit
him like you okay and then help him up
like dude
stick it to finish him yeah finish him
finish him dude
i was yelling kill him it's like jesus
christ it's his first class
sweep the leg yeah yeah it's interesting
but bosti is different bossie has that
mean streak
he does yes yeah he does man he sure
does i took him to pf changs a couple
weeks ago and he was
just waiting he slapped his mom the
other day yeah
nice yeah extra juice
we've got some good relationship advices
today okay
hey brendan hey theo this is jessica
from washington state
i have a relationship advice question
for you
if you were in a relationship would you
guys discuss
your one free hall pass whether it be a
celebrity or
somebody just one time
one and done no questions asked um would
you guys allow that would that piss you
off
um mine is theo if i ever bumped into
him
who was going there let me know gang
gang buzz
[Laughter]
oh she likes his old tired fellas huh
you're all tired
if you're in a relationship you down for
the one the hall pass
you know i think it's it it's like if
you set here's
think people don't set that up well in
the beginning people will say oh mine
is like julia roberts and then your girl
is like
oh mine is that guy that works as the
manager over at uh macaroni grill
c every friday like what but you've
already made the deal yeah
it's like [ __ ] yeah i'm like that's a
good point yeah am i ever gonna meet
julia roberts that's not
happening also if you got a hot chick
she can just dm whoever she wants and
she's probably gonna have a shot
if i damn [ __ ] cardi b she's not
gonna hit me back you feel me yeah
that's my hall pass also it's different
man i got kids yeah i'm not letting my
girl no hall pass man when kids are
involved i
i don't wanna see her you know if she's
like oh my hall pass is [ __ ]
odell beckham i don't think so man
um yeah i think it's tough what kind of
whole pass is good
you know jim what are you guys doing out
there with hall passes and you're
hell no i would never do hall pass i
break up before that happens
really yeah i don't have kids either
why do you say that man because you're
not down for it hell no nothing like
that
what about oral only kind of no not even
kissing no
no not even like uh holding hands or is
my friend from boston used to say
a little bit of laurel a little bit
laurel
whatever you always say well i got with
this girl she gave me a little bit of
oral
the dude was like sick i was just saying
was your friend hella old
now who wants a man but golden chin i'm
sorry
that's it like if it's a girl the
younger generation's in that stuff
meatball you down for uh some hall
passes
with your next girl uh yeah i'd be down
for it i just
pray that i get my hall pass like i'd
like i'd meet the girl i'd have a hall
pass for like and be able to hook up
with her
and the girl i'm with never meets a guy
that she would want her hall pass for
well yeah anybody would pray for that
man that's your prayer that is just kind
of the way you would want your hall pass
to work out
and i respect your point that you're
right like my girls hall pass was
[ __ ] jeff
bezos it's like all right good luck with
that yeah and pick the local stripper
yeah mine's gonna be the girl that
brings amazon to our house yeah
you know what i'm saying you gotta aim
small with all passes dude that's the
smartest thing you ever said
you got out there don't shoot for the
stars man
yeah dude shoot for the stop sign yeah
shoot and shoot for pf change
oh dang this guy's not handsome
[Laughter]
all right boys i got a relationship
advice look you'll be fine
with those gimples you'll be all right
dude a two and a half year relationship
who broke up about a year ago never
stopped hooking up though
today she comes up to me and says
hey i think we should be in an open
relationship
because i want to end up with you i want
to get married to you
but we both got some fun we need to get
out of our system what's that long haul
pass
i don't know how to feel about this boys
i like my cake
i like to eat it too but i definitely
don't like sharing my cake
and since you're at it boys hit me with
that uh rate my state we out here in
a z born and raised in minnesota i'm six
four hundred and eighty
ch hey what's up can you attend man
don't be searching for compliments
wait he looks like c64180 yeah that
means he's shred city he's
lean and mean dog but how mean though is
a 180 to a strong wind could [ __ ] put
that dude in a hard scarf
yeah by being his cardio for days in his
shredville dog
but how shredded like dude i mean what
you're talking about
on skin you're talking about you could
smell marrow in his breath yeah this
dude you can't have that much
180 is not brennan i'm 184. you pricey
is lungs
yeah you hold the light looks like a
leaf
i found his instagram i found this oh
you found him he's a stone cold tan man
he looks like mario lopez if he didn't
do all that botox
he's a good looking dude with them
dimples huh i don't see it aceley bader
huh
i don't see it really you don't think
he's good-looking human i mean i think
he's handsome but i'm trying not to
think about it
oh there's his body click on the one
where he's sitting in the [ __ ] aztec
place yeah that lighting the chair's not
very wide he's very
lean he's super thin
get some hairy nips huh oh there's this
girl who's trying to [ __ ] everybody
oh he's really lean man
yeah that was weird he was like oh his
jeans have tears that i'm like
uh can i see that ass on the left
come on daddy do you not see the girl
that just got done at the rave
dude he's uh that's the girl from
beverly hills 90210
dude tori spelling
uh yeah go back again click on her
though let's see
because she's looking for me you might
be her long haul pass
you think yeah he might be her extended
stay of dick dude no this ain't the same
lady
that is that's his girl dude no this
lady's from washington
yeah they're both from washington moved
arizona whoa no different girl
nope that's his girlfriend dude no the
girl that sent the video that was
excited about me though that's not her
oh we're not worried about her dude
we're talking about her
i still have to start a family brendan
okay i'm not like you and chin and
freaking everybody else in here except
freaking
nugget fart over there no it's meatball
too my bad buddy you're doing good
[Music]
i'm just joking man i love you meatballs
are you down for a long haul pass
not chan nick you down for a long haul
pass no
we've had a similar discussion like what
it sounds cool but i get way jealous
yeah no no not me and my girlfriend oh i
was guessing oh
i thought you and your girl had a long
discussion sounds like she's into it oh
no she wouldn't be down and i won't be
down either my girl's way too jealous
really way too jealous i don't have a
girl but if i did
i don't know what i feel like you're
getting that vibe
lucy go with the flow wherever the wind
takes me dude the wind usually takes me
over to some cocaine i know that
i don't know that yeah i know that yeah
so
i want to just keep the breeze out of my
hair baby that's what i'm trying to do
look it's rob riggles
hey king in the sting sitting here in
the er with a 103.1
temperature i was british getting that
drip drip
hitter okay looking like some infected
kidney stones they think
waiting on ct can't scan results
uh i kind of thought of like a would you
rather
type question for you guys all right so
the doctor's telling me
he's on drugs it's infected kidney
stones they have to
manually extract them right away which
would entail going up through the
pee hole oh you got to do you know so it
kind of got me thinking
higher if i had to be awake for that
procedure and only get like a
local and had to watch it would you guys
rather
watch them take out infected kidney
stones through your urethra
or watch yourself with only a local
anesthetic
get circumcised gang gang
er buzz buzz yeah he's er buzz this
fellas on [ __ ] drugs yeah he's on that
[ __ ] codeine or something huh oh yeah
he's on he's on that scissor
he's on that local [ __ ] cedar scissor
he's on that weenie lane yep this dude's
on [ __ ] drugs man and i don't i wouldn't
make a video if i'm gonna hide on [ __ ]
drugs
me neither man his eyes are barely open
this dude's about to go digging down his
own wiener hole first try to get a bunch
of filipino nurses right up his dick
hole that's what's happening man
dude this is where you hire david blaine
i would just have somebody magically
take that [ __ ] out you know
sure you're going to lose your watch but
who cares yeah it's worth it
yeah it's worth it man but good luck
look man
and no r.i.p man i heard passing those
kidney stones is the worst pain of
all time really seen them yeah they're
like little spikes like porcupines going
through your [ __ ] pee hole
my brother had to do it so it was like
the worst pain of his life
god and now this is also a kid because
when he was a child
he had ingrown toenail so bad he kept
cutting them kept cutting them
finally they had to tear his toenails
off
said to take a needle inject underneath
the toenail
and then rip it out so they didn't have
toenails on his big toe
your brother yeah oh my god it's like
two thumbs
it's like two hairless thumbs oh my
god and he's and he said that was the
worst pain until he got had to pass
kidney stones
what's next for him huh
something bad will happen to him
probably unfortunately hopefully not
hopefully maybe right now you can even
hear those ambos man
r.i.p that might be the dick guy big j
and here's a guy right here dude here's
crow cop we'll close it out with the
debate club here's john goodman
[Laughter]
what's up guys it's kyle from st louis
what's up kyle club for you guys
it's one of my worst fears ever look
what if you got a [ __ ]
really bad and you're flying home i mean
it's coming out
you're like do i pull over the side of
the road and [ __ ] or hit the subway
you're trying to make it home all sudden
the cherries come on you're getting
pulled over
what the [ __ ] so do you just pull over
and [ __ ] your pants yeah or do you
[ __ ] just
take them on high speed and do the dash
all the way home i think i'm doing the
high speed hop it out with their hands
up
i got a [ __ ] i swear it might tase you
and you [ __ ] your pants anyway i don't
know
buzz buzz gang gang
well first of all you have an empty van
you could easily defecate in the rear of
that van
and you could wash that thing out of the
car wash my mom has the same van
and so there's nothing in the back it's
just metal yeah doing [ __ ] on that metal
dog yeah
when i was a kid by a kid i mean 16 i
[ __ ] in a slurpy cup
it was pouring rain outside after [ __ ]
oh me and my brother were working
so i went in the back of the u-haul and
[ __ ] in a slurpee cup oh
soft-serve baby ugh disgusting yeah my
brother threw up
i just like this guy's energy it was a
little vulgar topic but for sure
yeah he seemed like a good guy he seemed
like a guy who didn't mind you know who
loves to [ __ ] honestly
some of the guy's gonna [ __ ] his pants
for sure yeah and here he is
after a total
180 man it's amazing how much the cold
will hold man
how much bad juju the colon will hold
here he is
after he finally found a place to
defecate and now he wants to show us
his tattoos what is up garlic parm in
louisiana liquor aka brendan and theo
uh i am here for a sink my ink
um as you can tell got a bunch of them
by the way my name is
got the dead rabbit over here you know
gangs in new york
uh leonardo dicaprio shout out best one
and the best to ever do it okay
we'll move on to the pirate theme at the
pittsburgh pirates p got that skull
the blade ship um ninja turtles over
here
ellie oh yeah get that kill hands down
of course
uh daughter's birth flower daughter's
name
[Music]
go on to the neck neck's pretty cool
that's a mirror pretty good and then i
got a few in my head
you can't really see because of the
lettuce growing back here yeah
but one of the other ones chicago bulbs
wow i'm not doing so great right
now looking better but uh let's run with
us go bulls
gang gang buzz buzz thank you for your
time that boys tatted up that dude is
tatted up his first video he sent in it
was two minutes and 40 seconds
explaining all the tattoos
so we gotta go a little quicker that's
why he has the stopwatch oh
i love that thank you nick for doing
that yeah thank you for listening you
seem like a nice guy and you seem like
you like
art well he just wants to commentate on
his tattoos
uh yeah sink his ink the [ __ ] is lit man
you get that neck tattoo daddy if you're
not in entertainment is that
but this guy i think is a good judge of
how tattoos look on him it seems like
like his vibe
oh made yeah some people you see them
you're like
doesn't last insane yeah it just doesn't
work yeah
and they can't do anything about it yeah
but uh but i like
working was dope yeah for white guy with
tattoos i really dig that man um
i think that guy's doing well you only
have the one tat on the lower back the
[ __ ] stamp
i don't have any i thought you got a
[ __ ] stamp nope
you don't have a [ __ ] stamp no i got
two straps that's
it that's it did you ever did anybody
else think you had a [ __ ] stamp
no really how the [ __ ] have you made it
through life with no
tattoos look at him a uh
meatball you have any tats you got any
ink i got uh
three what is it uh let it sink your
[ __ ] name
i got um stand in between them yeah
yeah what is it meatball people
you freaking little you standing between
them yeah you gotta get behind one of
them
because the only way the camera can see
uh i got a mac miller tattoo when he
died oh yeah
uh oh yeah i got oh damn daddy trying to
get that [ __ ]
i got my great grandmother she's 98
years old i got her favorite
say her name uh my great-grandmother
name's claire
uh i got this tattoo it's her favorite
set of rosy beads she's still alive
though
still kicking you think we could shave
down that armpit here though
[Laughter]
not my whole body but i'll trim the
armpits there my man
dude are you enrolling in the army or
what's going on here get in the military
dude
no no i'm just do this whole get up dude
you look like a military can we be
finished
get in the military get in the military
kid
okay put you on drones and fly around
you could drive the drones like star
wars like the ewoks dog
yeah dude you look like a [ __ ] future
p.o.w bro
so figure it out okay
get out it's me ball god
god that's it that's mag is fine
there you go dude what a way to close it
out meatball took his shirt off
magga's little five whole goes maggot
[Applause]
i should just get blm tattooed on my
neck or my face or something
that's not going to do it in your face
what else do we have man
that's it that's it doggie i'm in
oklahoma june what is it chin
june 10th through the 12th or some [ __ ]
like that
oklahoma city brickstown comedy club we
got a bunch more dates
june 10th to 12th y'all i called it june
10th through the 12th bricks
bricks town comedy club in oklahoma city
we got a bunch of more dates hitting the
hitting the site because uh shit's
opening up yeah so i'm like the rat cam
start doing more touring
dang well i'm not touring just yet but i
will be i'll be in st
louis and cincinnati charlotte durham i
got a just a tour kind of
popping off later this year so
chattanooga knoxville wilmington
wilkes bar minneapolis baltimore
richmond charleston albany buffalo in
columbus
you're all over daddy daddy's show
well it's just you know i'm gonna be in
there and uh i'm excited about it so
thanks for the support theovan.comtour
and uh get you some maybe we'll have to
do some shows together maybe let's do it
brother it'd be fun
new sick boy merch drops tonight friday
well this drops on thursday but tomorrow
sickboy.com thick boy [ __ ] season
i'll see you in the [ __ ] ring tiger
oh all right sorry brendan and theo
fighter and weight i got to go in and go
hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso and the
quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you